[Music]
everybody
all I have got a couple videos to shoot
today and uh quite frankly it is 70
degrees out in DC today and there is
zero chance I'm going to be shooting
those indoors Drex here from drexfactor
POI sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm coming at
you with a review of zip POI from
juggling calling but before we dive into
that I just want to give a quick shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
Ultra POI for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca becklenen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
so this is wild it is the last week of
February and uh this magnolia tree in
the courtyard the apartment complex
where I live you're starting to see buds
on the uh on on the flowers which is
totally wild and yes this is very much a
byproduct of climate change that is
happening this early in the year but you
know what I tend to have problems with
seasonal depression and this is the most
mild that that has been in years so two
things can be true at the same time it
can be both apocalyptic from a climate
perspective and also I can appreciate it
from a mood perspective now clearly my
usual review rubric is not going to be
very effective here because that review
rubric really centers around LED props
and these are definitely not LED props
I'm not even really sure what product
category they fall into because as we'll
discuss
um they don't really function like
normal contact boys so I don't know that
I can review them from that perspective
all right then so
let's talk some turkey here zip POI what
exactly are these so as I understand it
these are kind of a new idea for a set
of poi that came from French POI spinner
bow juggler or I guess I should say uh
French POI juggler bow juggler now the
theory behind it is that you basically
take the same kind of setup that you get
with contact POI wherein you have a
stage ball that has a hole drilled in it
and a rope going into it with a handle
connected to it but you turn both ends
into the handle so like if you look real
carefully at the balls here you'll note
that the hole going into them is much
bigger than it normally would be even
for a rope of this size which I want to
say this is uh 3 8 maybe half inch rope
and so that makes it so that you can
easily Slide the head back and forth
along the length of the Rope of course
the Rope itself is static rope so it
becomes one of those situations where
you can get the Rope to stand up on end
and you can slide the POI head back and
forth along its whole length so let's
answer one of the obvious questions
early on does the head slide back and
forth fairly easily on these tethers yes
it does just so long as you can keep the
tether fairly straight the the ball
really will not get hung up on this
another obvious question can you use
these for traditional POI spinning yes
you absolutely can it kind of feels like
spinning around baseball bats in some
respects simply because there's now so
much weight at the other end because
it's not just the head now but also a
handle but yeah there wasn't anything
with traditional POI spinning that I
tried that didn't feel like it was
doable with these and of course are they
any good for contact POI spinning
well so for all that you might gain by
having a handle at each end of these POI
one of those things that you lose is the
complete spherical form factor of the
head you wind up with something that's a
little off from that and I have found
that that tends to make contact poi
quite a bit more challenging
um some basic contact roles like just
forearm rolls seem to work more or less
just like they would otherwise with a
little bit of adjustment
but uh things like folding lines are
really really really a big challenge
with these okay so then in that case do
these open up any new avenues and the
answer to that is yes most definitely
now there's already no shortage of
videos online of bojuggler using these
in a variety of different ways and of
course some other Spinners like uh voita
stobenko and inevitably what you see
there is kind of a fusion of some
traditional POI moves as well as some
stuff that is like very very very deep
into the manipulation world and also
very very deep into kind of the POI as
circus prop World a lot of this tends to
focus around tosses negative space and
finding interesting balances with these
it's a very very very specific style
that I think of as kind of a subset of
either Tech POI or circus POI fusion
um but it's kind of something that
doesn't have much of a context in
traditional POI spinning at least not
that I've seen and of course it's off
also a very different style of poi
spinning than I traditionally do I
definitely had a learning curve when I
was trying to figure out some tricks
that I had seen both bow juggler as well
as voita doing in their videos and it
took me more than a little bit of time
to figure out exactly what was going on
and how to duplicate a lot of that work
there's definitely a system at play with
these where now you have to consider not
just the alignment of the POI but where
gravity is at and of course where you
can move your hands to in order to take
advantage of different elements of
gravity what part of the POI you're
grabbing onto because you can now grab
onto the handle and let the head move
freely or you can grab onto both the
head and the handle to lock the head in
place or you can just grab onto the head
and in some cases allow the tether to
move freely so there are some things
that I like about this setup and there's
some things that I really don't now
playing around with these I definitely
felt that itch from back in the Heyday
of my tech POI years back around like
2010 to 2012. I felt that familiar kind
of itch in the back of my head when I
started to use these and seeing that
there was a system here that could be
explored if you are big into POI as a
system and specifically things like
Frameworks and Tech work then these are
probably up your alley but by the same
token if you're just starting off on
your POI Journey or you have a really
specific style that doesn't necessarily
have that much to do with manipulation
or circus style POI
um you're probably not going to find a
lot here that's going to appeal to you I
will say one of the things that I'm
really intrigued about with these is
that they offer the potential to go back
and forth between a traditional POI
alignment where you have both of your
hands tracing around the same Circle
versus an anti-bred alignment where you
have one hand tracing around the path of
the opposite POI head so I can see some
great examples which this is usually a
challenge for me and my own POI spinning
of switching back and forth between the
two fairly easily and by the same token
I will confess I really have not been
super motivated to pick these up and
really explore the system of them unless
I was working on a video associated with
them so
I I'm not sure how heavily I'm going to
be using these in the coming months or
years
um but that doesn't mean that I won't
pick them up at some point and go deep
like you know contact boy were around
for years before there was enough of a
vocabulary around them for everybody to
want to pick up sets now if you do want
to pick up a set of zip POI for yourself
they are available from juggling calling
they have both a website as well as an
Etsy store these are currently available
only on the Etsy store I will go ahead
and leave a link to that down in the
description
and they are currently available at for
like 93 dollars and uh I think it was 13
cents which is an oddly specific number
and I think there's a conversion factor
there from Euros in play but um yeah you
should go check those out if you want to
check out a pair they're definitely
something very different and for a lot
of people different and Novelty is good
if you're one of those types of people
then these are definitely worth checking
out but what do you think do you own a
set of zip poy from juggling calling
what are your thoughts on them do you
enjoy the new system associated with
them do you find them a good way to open
up new creative Avenues
um or do you likewise find them a little
ungainly to spin with leave me your
comments and let me know and if you got
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
both to help other people find it as
well as to help my channel grow
foreign
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helps make this video and all the videos
on this channel possible thank you one
and all for your very very generous
support and if you out there watching uh
would like to sign up to be a supporter
because you're not currently you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you and if you would like to check
out some of my other equipment reviews
you can do that by checking out the
playlist of videos that I have linked to
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you're watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look as well
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out to spend today and I will see
you with a brand new video very soon
peace